hey everyone so recently there's been
some new leaks set photos for Avengers
for now for those of you who don't know
too much about the speculation around
Avengers for its heavily believed to be
a time travel movie and now with some
new leaked set photos and reports from
the set it is pretty much confirmed that
it is in fact a time travel movie in the
leaked set photos that we got before we
saw Tony Stark with much blonder hair
and ant-man and Captain America in his
original Captain America uniform and it
looks like they're in the Battle of New
York from the first Avengers movie
they're also wearing these little
wristbands that have these X's on them
that are widely believed to be some sort
of Pym technology or barf technology or
a combination of both and they're
believed to be the devices that allow
them to go back in time so what are the
new set photos show the new set photos
that we saw where Tony Stark dressed up
as a SHIELD agent particularly a SHIELD
agent that is escorting a captured Loki
on the Helicarrier and there were
reports from on set that said that they
saw the blonde hair future or present
Tony Stark with the original Tony Stark
from the Avengers one movie and this
pretty much confirms it for us because
we all know that Tony Stark was not
dressed up at any point in time as a
SHIELD agent in the first Avengers movie
and the reports from on set also
obviously confirm that it's a time
travel movie since these very first set
photos were leaked and if you've seen
Avengers infinity war you can clearly
tell that this is the route that they'll
have to take Avengers 4 so the question
is why is Tony Stark dressed up as a
SHIELD agent escorting Loki and I think
that the answer is pretty simple Loki
will be the key in Avengers 4 to
defeating Thanos after the Battle of New
York after the loss that Loki takes with
the Chitauri I think that instead of
sending Loki back to Asgard Tony Stark
and Captain America and ant-man are
gonna show up and they're gonna tell him
exactly everything that happens in
Avengers infinity war and obviously Loki
will want to somehow change
the future if you've seen in Finn
anywhere you know what I'm talking about
if you haven't get on it why haven't you
yet and I think look you might be a
little skeptical at first but I think
once they begin to talk to Thor and Loki
about the Infinity stones and how dire
the situation is and what happens in
infinity war then I think they will
realize and understand exactly how
detrimental Loki is going to be in the
plan to defeat Thanos in Avengers 4 and
then from there I think they'll somehow
figure out a way to send Loki and
possibly all the other adventures to
Thanos before the events of Avengers and
Finn anywhere happen I think that's the
only chance that they have at the
feeding danos but I will be doing more
about this theory in a separate video
coming really soon so that's it for this
video did you happen to check out any of
these leaked photos did you see some
before they got taken down because I
know some got taken down but most
importantly let me know your thoughts
let me know what you think is going to
happen in Avengers 4 if you enjoyed this
video hit that thumbs up button please
and don't forget about our giveaway all
you have to do is subscribe to my
channel the rest of the details are in
the description below thank you so much
for watching woof woof
[Music]
you